you might like to put up as well as
percentages even though we did it like a
couple lessons ago right percentages are
really just another way of saying
fractions they just say it and I'm gonna
do it down as well right because
sometimes it's easier to say things as a
fraction sometimes it's easy and set as
a percentage depending on what the exact
numbers I'll show you an example okay
they're both talking about proportions
when you divide things up in parts okay
so suppose you've got 100 people okay a
hundred people and you might say well
okay we can ball up and 50 of them are
girls 50 and 100 okay so you might say
50 out of 100 okay now that's the same
as like as a fraction we looked at
simplifying fractions didn't we
what would that end up if you put it in
you in its simplest form it's just a hub
right so that's the same as a hub and
you would just as likely say half of the
group students are girls right but we
want to use this new ways different way
of saying because 50% right
it literally means 50 out of a hundred
that's what percent means see this thing
right per since okay so the words like I
think I'm pretty sure they're matter
okay they mean out of that's the per
okay and there's no set century
Centipede century and all things that
have to do with a hundred right
centimeter and so on check out
okay so if 50 percent means out of 100
right these are all these different ways
of saying the same thing okay now we'd
say you know half of the students who
got half the group these girls we don't
mean this like half a girl and 99 half
boys right we mean that as a proportion
of the whole group that's just one more
way that we could say all the same thing
okay if you got your calculator out in
fact get your calculator out for me if
you put there for [ __ ] button go down
calculates at least I'm pretty sure
there is no my [ __ ] is that oh yeah okay
yeah it is above the left right yeah you
can then we have number one or two be
hard to follow and number two you won't
be able use your phone later like in the
assessment okay so you really for all of
you who have been using your phones as a
calculator has a subject calculator
definitely better than nothing but it's
easier just to practice with these thing
because that's the one you're gonna be
stuck with long term okay so you don't
want to get into any day and be like I'm
not allowed to use this thing but this
is what I'm used to using and then
you're like we get your food you can
either by now
now when you put any of these into your
calculator right what I'll spit back to
you if you put it into a decimal is
we'll be looking at that's what we look
to that last lesson right what are these
three as a decimal it's 0.5 that's
exactly right okay so all of these are
the same thing okay what you got is what
do we have over here you're a fraction
okay I guess this is the same fraction
but it's it's simplified that's a
simplified fraction
this is the percentage this is the main
thing to kind of focus on you and this
is our decimal now just like with our
metric units of length one of the
important things you need to be able to
do is convert between all of these okay
because they are all equivalent they're
just different ways to say the same
thing okay now what is useful why don't
I just stick with saying well this fifty
girls okay let me give you another table
that's sort of similar but make the
numbers moving up suppose I told you
there are a hundred and fifty girls in
the grade okay now you might look at
that and think well that's fairly normal
isn't it like that seems like it's about
half for you guys so that's this no
surprises there fine okay
but if I went to a different school for
example the school I used to be at 150
is the whole grade so if I told you is
150 girls in the grade that'd be very
unusual right so what we've got here
right just I suppose we would call it a
constant number
okay oh you know it's the actual value
that's how many girls there are it's not
useful to help us think about like
understand is there a lot is there not
many whereas these are all quite useful
right no matter what size the group is
if like your grade is 300 or if is 150
or if this you know five million of them
these will still tell you the same kind
of information bother this so therefore
let's have a look at some these question
is I think I mentioned page 24 it's
exercise 1f okay so it's not so pretty
simply right let's do one any together
okay they ask you two things for each of
these they give you a percentage fifteen
percent and they asked you to write in
two ways number one as a common fraction
so let's do that one first as a common
fraction yep
okay no yeah that's right okay so it's
course now how do we know like that was
close right the way you know is by
remembering all of this stuff say this
example here hopefully you find it
instructive this is 15 percent 15
percent which means 15 out of a hundred
so another way you could write this is
as 15 out of 100 that's the same thing
that's the point of this okay but for
you now you can think back to what we
looked at on the fractions on how to
simplify what's the biggest number that
I can divide the top and bottom by it's
5 that's exactly right so you do the
swap and you'll get 3 and then you do
the bottom and you divide by 5 remember
then you get 20 20 okay 5 2500 they go
okay so there you go there's 15 percent
there's a common fraction part 2 where
they asked what they asked for as a
decimal that's this guy
right so you can see another way of
looking at this is uh you know it's
50/50
this is really 0.5 0 there right so it's
kind of like kind of like the 50 just
goes after the decimal point okay so I
can do the same thing with 15 percent
it's going to be 0 points and now I put
the percent bit right
1/5 that's it as a decimal . and of
course if you went to your calculator
and you said 3 divided by 20
it should tell you 0 4 1 5 as well now
it's much the same thing to go back and
forth suppose for instance you got 3
over 20 right and we already know in
advance then it's going to be 15 percent
but how would you work that out how
would you put what working would you put
down 3 over 20 and you want to convert
that into a percentage what would you do
well yeah just like before CR we divided
by 5 this way here I'm gonna multiply by
5 I might even write that down multiply
by 5 on the top which means you've got a
multiple of that 5 on the bottom you see
my fine shinobi in P because it will
give you out of 115 over 100 and that's
50% okay so let's get what Lucas was
saying before right suppose I gave you
three quarters and we want to turn that
into a percentage so what should i
multiply by here
you multiply by five top and bottom what
do I multiply here by remember I want
this bottom number to become a hundred
right just like it did here four times
something gives me a hundred what is it
25 isn't it four times 25 and you can
check it on your calculator
so you did the bottom so you should do
the top as well so it's 2550 75 75 over
a hundred so that's 75% major now I
think the rest of those sort of foolish
super though they'll provide units on it
for example what's 75 percent of some
number of dollars or what's 15% of some
number of meters so all the adding is
units but it's the same idea okay so